You don't know everything about me
The Avengers weren't my first family.
At some point we all have to
choose
Between, what the world wants you to be
And who you are.
Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie happy Superbowl so they just
dropped the new Marvel Black Widow Super
Bowl trailer there's a bunch of Easter
eggs there's a bunch of new scenes that
also clear up the timeline of the actual
movie quite a bit so we'll break it all
down we're doing that infinity saga box
set giveaway for all the blu-rays all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video so the big theme of
the trailer is all about her speaking to
the ellen of Bulova black widow telling
her I had a family before the Avengers
telling her about David Harper's red
Guardian character Alexei Shostakov
funny thing because he was in stranger
things there was an Alexei character
there so r.i.p Alexei from stranger
things but he's also meant to be the
Russian version of Captain America he
got a diluted version of the Super
Soldier Serum the way David Harper
explains his character is that he was
this great hope for the Russian people
the Soviets when they created him
thought that he was really going to be
the next best Captain America he didn't
give away why they considered him a
failure something happened at some point
in the past he refused their orders and
they threw him in prison that's what you
see all these scenes of him fighting and
what looks like the prison yard he's
still crazy strong like Captain America
is strong because of that Super Soldier
Serum but as you can see he's gone to
seed just a little bit because he's been
in prison for so long one of the
greatest jokes in the previous trailer
is when he says it's mostly water weight
anyone who's ever played sports in high
school or college probably remembers
somebody talking about water weight but
within their little family unit he was
sort of her surrogate father and then
you have to imagine that the milena
Vostok off Black Widow the one that
played by Rachel Vice was her surrogate
mother and we literally heard Yelena
Belova call her sister so that's sort of
what their family is like but this is
all happening after the events of
Captain America Civil War we see her in
that new Black Widow costume it's very
much made to look like the comic book
Black Widow costume with the golden
gauntlets and because you see them all
standing here in the wreckage of
whatever it is that they dive-bomb off
of this big building that's being
destroyed the footage basically confirms
that this is the next version of the
Black Widow costume it's not a flashback
scene because you all see them standing
around here some of them in the white
costumes from earlier in the trailer the
white Black Widow costume is also a deep
cut for the comics there's just a couple
big black widow comic book things that
the movies have never done that
now they're doing because this is all
about her character it's still not
totally clear what it is they're blowing
up here high in the sky it's easy just
some building or some part of the Black
Widow program because a lot of this
conversation hedges on her trying to
turn Yelena Belova away from the dark
side of the force it sounds like that
also happened with her family in the
past - like I said David Harper's
character read Guardian thrown in prison
we don't really know where Molina vostok
off character has been this whole time
there's a bunch more footage of the
taskmaster character now because a lot
of the voiceover talks about not being
who the state wants you to be obviously
they're talking about the Russian state
then trying to turn them into weapons it
sounds like the taskmaster is also a
separate character that is created by
the red-room program or at least is
associated with it I don't think that
means the taskmaster is going to suddenly
turn good but I think that also implies
the Thunderbolts arc that a lot of
people have been talking about
Thunderbolts supposed to be featured at
some point during the Black Widow movie
and during the Falcon and Winter Soldier
Avengers series that's going to be
happening in present day just to be
clear all the Disney Plus stuff the
Falcon Winter Soldier stuff Wanda vision
that takes place after Avengers endgame
the majority of the events of the Black
Widow movie take place between Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war but there's a lot of theories about
a post-credits scene being said in
present day with them putting the
Thunderbolts team together
taskmaster is just one of the prime
candidates because he was a member of
the team in the comics and because he's
just such an interesting character with
unusual powers like you literally see
him pull a Captain America when he
stomps on his shield and picks it up
that's right out of the elevator scene
very famous elevator scene in Captain
America Winter Soldier the reason why he
can do that is because he probably
watched footage of Captain America
inside that elevator obviously that was
all Hydra stuff going on at this time
but Black Widow released all the Hydra
files in all the shield files publicly
so literally everybody in the Russian
government taskmaster they would have
been able to see all that stuff there's
also a deleted scene from Captain
America Winter Soldier that connects to
what's happening with the Black Widow
movie there's some plot points that
they'll pick up on there was a scene
where she's talking to Alexander Pierce
and she's slowly unlocking all the
shield files getting ready to release
them and he's trying to stop her from
doing that the audio is a little janky
for some reason but it's still a pretty
good scene
what are you doing she's disabling
security protocols and dumping all the
secrets under the Internet including
hydras and shields if you do this none
of your past is going to remain hidden
now Budapest not Osaka not the
children's ward.
Are you sure you're ready for
the world to see you as you really are
are you
we'll look out the window it doesn't
matter what our enemies think about us
anymore
that's why they're going down a pretty
high opinion of Rogers chances clearly
you haven't been paying attention.
so during that
Alexander Pierce is trying
to throw her past the red on her ledger
in her face and obviously during these
trailers the Black Widow trailer she's
talking about not running from her past
anymore
so a lot of this is just picking up a
lot of the slack that they left with
unanswered questions about her past what
happened what are all these things that
they're referencing during these
previous movies Budapest is just the one
that everybody thinks of because they
referenced Budapest so many times most
recently during Avengers endgame when
she and Hawkeye were headed to four
mirror Jeremy Renner was posting a whole
bunch right before they dropped this I
still do have a theory that he'll have
some sort of cameo at the end of the
Black Widow movie that will address how
he met her in Budapest and offered her
spot on shield offered her a chance to
make her life better pretty much the
same speech that she's giving to Yelena
Belova during the course of this Black
Widow Super Bowl trailer I know there's
still a lot of theories about who the
taskmaster character is secretly going
to be because he's got his comic book
mask on the whole time I still think
it's going to be the Mason character
who's played by ot here I don't know how
to pronounce his last name so I don't
want to mess it up but I believe it's
going to be his character that's my
early theory right now a lot of you have
also asked if they're going to feature
Easter eggs for other big Marvel comic
book Russian characters like Crimson
Dynamo really big character that we
haven't seen a whole lot from in the
Marvel movies Crimson Dynamo is an Iron
Man character there's a lot of rumors
about Danny jr. having some deleted
scene cameo during the Black Widow
movies some sort of flashback to the
events of Captain America Civil War but
it's going to be deleted footage from
Captain America Civil War not Robert
Downey jr. coming back to film new
scenes connecting Black Widow two more
Iron Man stuff just because Iron Man
permeates the Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies so much because they're built on
his foundation whiplash big Russian
character was the main villain of Iron
Man 2 although he's presumed dead at the
end of that movie there's always ways to
bring him back
obviously Justin Hammer is also a prime
candidate for a Thunderbolts project
whether that happens on Disney Plus or
in the movies but there's a surprising
amount of Black Widow connected Russian
Marvel comic book characters that have
been happening in the MCU
all the Winter Soldier stuff with Hydra
happening in Siberia is a little bit
separate from the red-room stuff though
there's a lot of questions about what's
going on with
soldier obviously we have the Falcon and
Winter Soldier series coming up I'm sure
there's going to be some sort of
flashbacks during that to his past he's
also clearing read off of his ledger
still considered a war criminal by the
US government - in general Ross during
Captain America Winter Soldier she said
that she ran afoul of him in the past
when she was still acting as a black
widow with the red-room program so it's
possible that they include some moment
or some reference from that it would be
weird to not have Winter Soldier
featured in at least some small way
during the movie for the most part the
biggest surprises that I'm expecting
would be Thunderbolts related maybe some
sort of black widow post-credit scene
with general Thunderbolt Ross just
because he's featured so prominently in
all the trailers I just feel like
they're going to try and connect this to
present day somehow I saw a lot of you
making fantastic for John Krasinski
jokes because he showed up in a Super
Bowl trailer with Chris Evans doing some
funny stuff it was mostly meant to be a
parody this was an ad that they did a
commercial so this isn't them saying
that he's going to be mr. fantastic in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or
anything it's just a funny coincidence
because they're both from Boston and
they're doing they're funny Boston
accents during the trailer I know
everyone's been posting the fan art of
John Krasinski as mr. fantastic and
Emily Blunt
as the Invisible Woman she would be
amazing in any Marvel movie she was
their original choice to be Black Widow
and Iron Man - she wasn't able to do it
because of a scheduling conflict that's
actually how Scarlett Johansson wound up
becoming the black widow of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there were reports
recently that Emily Blunt was meeting
with Marvel about taking a major role in
a future movie we don't know if that was
a Fantastic Four movie or if that was
for say like the Clea character during
Doctor Strange - because they're getting
ready to go into production on Doctor
Strange - in the next couple of months
so if we get any more news about that or
Marvel's new Fantastic Four movie of
course I'll do a video about it so
everyone posts all your theories in the
comments below how are they going to
connect this movie to present day even
though it's set during the past and all
the other stuff that just happened
recently during Avengers endgame there's
supposed to be a trailer for The
Avengers Falcon in Winter Soldier series
dropping really soon as well as a one
division trailer I don't know when
that's going to happen but of course I'll
do videos for it when they do if there's
any big requests that you guys have just
leave them in the comments below
everyone click here for my brand new
Avengers 5 and Marvel phase 5 video and
click here for my brand new Marvel
Eternals teaser breakdown
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!